hello my name is Joe Parra every year on
Valentine's Day a lot of people were
read to be festive but I instead were
black out of respect for all the ladies
hearts I've broken with this smile that
was just a joke there is a scroll that I
do like right now who told me
unfortunately that she's going to be
moving to Los Angeles at the end of the
summer I noticed a bad idea they keep
seeing her and almost definitely end in
disappointment but for me parkour master
there are no dead ends only walls off
which to do backflips
I gotta admit that joke is a bit dated
an hour and she sense moved to Los
Angeles and I've kind of learned that
I'm not quite as good at parkour as I
thought I was I think the reason I liked
her so much she's a tall woman a lot of
guys like women that are the same height
as them or shorter but I like the tall
ones because I want sons that can't be
outdone on the basketball court with all
humility I'll tell you that my sons are
going to dunk on your sons and then
they're going to pick the ups so that I
can dunk on you
now throw it to use the audience how
tall do you think my sons are going to
be sick 6 6 - Wow 7 foot tall 8 foot Wow
guys are going big right off the bat you
keep going ok I'll give you I'll give
you I'll give you a hint their legs will
be as long as six-year-old birches and
their arms will be as long as a
four-year-old birches
Oh feed that's crazy
where's attending the hair clothes for
little taller oh boy this is
overwhelming 10 and 3/4 a little bit
less 9 and 3/4
10 yeah yeah you're exactly right
my sons are going to be 10 feet tall cuz
I'm gonna feed him a steady diet of
whole milk oats and HGH human growth
hormone I wouldn't do that but um
sometimes I get so excited I'll use a
computer to mock up Christmas cards from
18 years down the line or so and all
[Music]
I started this this one person to show
joke yeah did you know your trees so you
get the price I guess you know your sons
oh that that's your son how tall is your
son
really Wow
you're very lucky okay well I didn't
expect to end the set talking about your
son's for them yeah this that's that's
all I got in congratulations on your son
[Applause]
you